I want our kids to be happy that's what
this is all about it's about the kids if
it weren't for you Melissa your girls
might not be the stars they are today
you spend most of your days at the ALDC
cheering them on and it wasn't all for
nothing Maddie and Mackenzie are huge
stars and they have to thank you for
that
there aren't many parents who would put
their lives on hold to encourage their
kids to follow their passions so we
guess what we're trying to say melissa
is Thank You Maddie Ziegler might be
coined as the most famous teenage dancer
in America but we're giving Mackenzie a
very different title we believe her to
be the most talented Dance Moms star to
ever appear on the show and we have the
facts to back it all up keep watching to
find out about Kenzie's long list of
wicked talents and accomplishments wrote
a book check make a blind check you act
in a series that you're the executive
producer of check you've done Dancing
with the Stars Junior check and you've
released your first signal single Kenzi
means business she may only be 15 years
old but Mackenzie Ziegler sure knows how
to build an empire people never fail to
compare it Kenzie to Maddie but in truth
they're very different people should she
keep saying that I have to do like it
like you but I'm not you Kinsey is only
20 months younger than Maddie but she's
managed to build a brand that's worth
three million dollars her net worth is
beyond impressive and she's still in
high school
gingy has social media in the bag
the youngest Ziegler sister knows a
thing or two about social media as of
August 20 1930 has a total of thirteen
point two million followers on Instagram
McKinsey isn't far behind
she has 13 million followers of her own
Kinsey isn't afraid to go outside of her
comfort zone some dancers like to play
it safe they stick to their preferred
genre and stop trying to challenge
themselves well that isn't the case for
Mackenzie she may not be the best
lyrical contemporary dancer but she has
amazing musicality she showed this off
while performing colors of the wind on
Dancing with the Stars juniors
that was absolutely breathtaking she's a
natural entertainer Maddie may be known
for making unique faces during her
performances McKenzie has a reputation
of her own she's a natural entertainer
who excels in many categories Mackenzie
is a gifted hip-hop dancer who also has
skills in the Acrobat tumbling
department Kinsey has a deep-rooted love
for music and it shows on her face every
single time she takes the stage
she's musically gifted on top of being a
badass dancer Kenzie is also known for
being a singer she's been releasing
songs since she was 10 years old and
she's got fans for days because she is
working on her second album
Kenzie performs the opening act for the
boy bands pretty much and has even done
venues all over the United States and
Toronto but that's not all she can do
Kenzie also plays the ukulele and the
piano
Kenzie's rules for life when Mackenzie
was 13 years old she decided to write a
book my sister got to write a book and I
was like I really want to beat her at
something so I really wanted to write a
book
however she knew that doing this alone
would be close to impossible so she
hired a ghostwriter to help her out in
kindy rules for life the young star
shares the lessons she learned and
promotes positivity amongst too many
other things from getting her start on
Dance Moms to traveling the country on a
sold-out tour
Kenzie covers it all acting credits a
lot of the og girls from Dance Moms went
on to land other minor roles in TV shows
and movies and Kennedy is one of them
however the young star is interested in
pursuing acting more and more as she
gets older Kenzie portrayed Dorothy and
there was devised she's appeared in a
few episodes of Nicky Ricky Dicky and
Dawn and she also played Cassie in
Holiday Spectacular and total eclipse
she's super funny
what makes Mackenzie even more loveable
is her amazing sense of humor you can
always catch her with a big smile on her
face she loves pranking her friends and
filming funny videos which is why a lot
of her fans can easily connect with her
she's a master multitasker
being a huge star isn't always easy
Mackenzie juggles her personal life
school work public appearances and more
but she always makes time for her
friends and family you have to be
extremely talented to juggle two very
different lives
Kenzie's unique wardrobe most teenagers
have no idea how to dress they're still
trying to figure out what works and what
doesn't but that's not the case for
Mackenzie she's confident and proud to
show off her unique wardrobe from
pulling off a vibrant blazer to looking
pretty in pink Kenzie can make any
outfit look trendy you wear something
black she's not afraid to be yourself
being authentic is something that fans
pick up on which is why they love
Mackenzie she's not afraid to be herself
and always makes herself vulnerable by
opening up to the world her song hot is
about her ex-boyfriend
Ashton barb he cheated on her but
instead of breaking down she turns her
heartache into music Kenzie loves her
fans being famous is cool and all but
it's important to give back to fans and
that's exactly what Kenzie does I'm
going to be talking to fans undercover
she's constantly interacting with her
followers and posting new videos
Mackenzie takes things a step further by
reposting her fans videos on tick-tock
she stays humble through it all
Mackenzie may have grown up in the
spotlight but she knows how important it
is to stay humble
despite liking Ariana Grande's music
Kenzie isn't a fan of the song seven
rings she finds it rude to brag about
money which is why she dislikes the song
it's easy to see that Mackenzie Ziegler
is multi-talented and downright
inspiring we loved this young star
because she isn't afraid to be herself
and try new things
what do you guys love about Kenzie sound
off in the comments give this video a
big thumbs up if you love Dance Moms and
be sure to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]